[Applauso]
giampaolo per me l'economia circolare e
lui
giampaolo era il vicino di casa di mia
nonna da cui passavo le estati quando
ero bambino giampaolo è quello che una
volta si sarebbe chiamato il matto del
paese bestemmiatore seriale urlatore
seriale faceva cose strane e diceva cose
stranissime stranissime certamente per
noi bambini ma anche per gli adulti
quella difficoltà
quel imperfezione quella fragilità erano
difficili da capire e da mettere a fuoco
ricordo giampaolo attraversare la piazza
nell'indifferenza della borgata non
rientrava nei canoni dell'ordinario di
quella piccola comunità di provincia
nessuno si aspettava alcun contributo da
lui e così tutti in un modo o nell'altro
lo ignoravano
e così avremmo dovuto fare anche noi i
bambini chiede i figli lo sa
vietare qualcosa di bambini è difficile
far rispettare il divieto è
ulteriormente difficile io non resistete
alla tentazione lo avvicina gli parlai e
fu la marachella di un bambino ricordo
quel giorno in cui parlammo insieme io
avevo 10 anni ero seduto sui gradini lui
era probabilmente maggiorenne in piedi e
mi parlava superata la soddisfazione di
aver commesso un piccolo reato
subentrò l'apprensione cosa avrebbe
combinato giampaolo un improvviso scatto
d'ira un'ennesima enorme bestemmia non
capito nulla di tutto questo
gli adulti non avevano ragione
parlammo parlando a lungo e la
percezione alla fine è che giampaolo
fosse molto meno strano di quello che i
grandi dicevano disse delle cose
interessanti o almeno credo perché un
bambino sta seduto ad ascoltare solo
cose che lo interessano se non scappa si
inventa qualcosa poi ci perdemmo di
vista
lui trovo lavoro e cambiò diventa
un'altra persona ed io ero diventato più
grande e più distratto meno interessato
a spendere tempo parlare con le persone
lui invece era un'altra persona non so
che lavora avesse trovato ma qualcuno lo
aveva trovato qualcuno aveva capito il
modo in cui attivare quel ragazzo così
speciale
qualcuno aveva capito meglio di come noi
lo avevamo capito quali doti avesse come
valorizzarle ed il ragazzo era veramente
cambiato anche esteticamente i capelli
lunghi
la barba folta la frangia su un occhio
la sigaretta di lato il maglioncino il
jeans asciutto la bicicletta pedalata
con fare deciso sicuro era splendido uno
splendido hipster badate non era
cambiato nulla
continuava a bestemmiare continua a
volare continua a fare cose strane ora
tutto si teneva tutto aveva un senso e
un significato giampaolo aveva trovato
la sua identità
giampaolo aveva trovato la sua
dimensione di benessere ed era
completamente fiorito ora dal mio punto
di vista
nella mia esperienza di ricerca
l'economia circolare è questo una
risorsa un rifiuto per alcuni inserito
in un contesto favorevole prospera e
produce valore per sé e per gli altri
dunque giampaolo è l'economia circolare
lo è perché rappresenta tutte le materie
ogni materia di cui non sappiamo cosa
fare perché non riusciamo più a vedere
quello che ci possono dare le
opportunità che offrono
e così questa materia rimane nel
sottoscala nel magazzino di un'azienda o
se va male e viene pure buttato in
discarica ma giampaolo e l'economia
circolare anche da un altro punto di
vista
giampaolo e tutti noi ognuno di noi ha
capacità e fragilità e se prevalgono le
seconde se veniamo valutati solo sulla
base delle nostre
tutti nessuno escluso si trova ai
margini impossibilitato incapace di
provvedere ai propri bisogni e di
accedere i propri diritti
quindi da questo punto di vista rifiuto
può essere qualunque cosa può essere un
materiale può essere una persona in un
momento di fragilità temporanea ma un
rifiuto sono anche le organizzazioni
incapaci di collaborare con altre realtà
rifiuti o d'opportunità inutilizzate
opportunità inespresse per me parlare di
economia circolare significa
essenzialmente parlare di questo come
attivare le risorse delle persone delle
comunità e delle organizzazioni
nient'altro che questo fosse facile
l'economia circolare e tutto questo da
anni lavoro su questa idea di
possibilità sulla possibilità che
esistano relazioni processi ambienti
sistemi capaci di attivare quelle
risorse di metterle in condizioni di
produrre valore per tutti questi sistemi
esistono funzionano se non esistono si
possono progettare e hanno una loro
sostenibilità basata essenzialmente sul
vantaggio reciproco delle relazioni che
collegano e fanno funzionare questo
sistema
mi occupo di questo da anni contribuisco
a progettare sistemi che attivano queste
risorse non lo faccio da solo anzi lo
faccio con persone più competenti di me
sui temi specifici del progetto dai
territori al benessere delle persone dai
materiali ai processi
questo è il range di progetti di cui ci
occupiamo il patto è sempre uno
il patto è sempre uno con chi progetta
al sistema e chi sta dentro quel sistema
produrre valore economico sociale
ambientale per i nodi del sistema e per
l'ambiente
mi sono occupato di tanti argomenti ma
alla convergenza di quei temi che vi di
cui vi ho parlato per cui territori
persone materiali processi sta il
progetto
di cui vorrei parlarvi oggi è il
progetto più piccolo di cui mi sono mai
occupato
si chiama un sacco di sport è un
progetto che parla di connessioni che
sembravano impossibili è un progetto che
ha realizzato un sistema che sopravvive
al progetto stesso
lo abbiamo pensato nel 2015 con colleghi
e colleghe da cui da anni con cui da
anni collaboriamo ai temi delle
connessioni impossibile è un progetto
che dimostra perfettamente la
reciprocità tra componenti così diverse
e così imperfette del sistema
i nodi di questa rete sono molti un
materiale dismesso già utilizzato per la
comunicazione di un grande evento
cittadino 220 studenti che sperimentano
il design ad impatto sociale
un'università che promuove
l'apprendimento anche basato sulla
pratica un'amministrazione comunale che
guarda a modelli di inclusione sociale
basati sull'idea di comunità e di
cittadinanza una rete di più di 50
laboratori che lavorano all'inclusione
sociale delle persone in condizioni di
fragilità attraverso i gesti preziosi
dell'artigianato e poi una bottega
agganciata a questa rete di laboratori
che valorizza questo lavoro è che
commercializza questo lavoro
i risultati concreti di questo progetto
sono una famiglia di prodotti una
famiglia di zaini borse sportive
contenitori personali che recupera ogni
centimetro ogni fibra del tessuto
dismesso che siamo stati in grado di
recuperare questi prodotti sono stati
progettati dagli studenti durante
un'esperienza didattica molto intensa e
molto emozionante sono stati adottati
dai laboratori sono stati realizzati
dalle persone che lavorano dentro i
laboratori in stretta collaborazione con
gli studenti gli uni imparando dagli
altri e poi questi prodotti hanno
trovato una vetrina dove raccontano
l'incontro di queste biografie e sono
stati messi in vendita commercializzati
tutti nodi
con una loro imperfezione ma nella
visione di sistema di questo progetto
sono tutti utili gli uni agli altri e
greg reggono il sistema per esempio i
tempi pazienti con cui le persone
lavorano al materiale con cui quei gesti
vengono osservati perché dicono molto di
come sta la persona di come sta
progredendo la persona sono
perfettamente coerenti con i tempi
regolari e le quantità ridotte con cui
il materiale periodicamente e
disponibile e lavorabile
e ancora l'apprendimento di competenze
progettuali e relazionali da parte degli
studenti procede di pari passo con lo
sviluppo che laboratori fanno dei loro
progetti
questi sono alcuni risultati che noi
riteniamo molto interessanti ma i valori
che questo sistema produce e che
permette a questo sistema di durare da
anni e di cui beneficiano tutti i
progetti che su questo sistema
transitano sono altri c'è il valore
delle relazioni tra persone che non si
conoscono e si scoprano reciprocamente
c'è il valore di cittadinanza il senso
di cittadinanza che viene sviluppato
dalla creatività collettiva di questo
progetto ci sono i proventi della
vendita di questi prodotti che
sostengono le attività di questi
laboratori così preziosi per la salute
delle persone e ci sono questi
laboratori che si aprono letteralmente
ai nuovi linguaggi che entrano umilmente
ma con entusiasmo attraverso i progetti
degli studenti
e poi ci sono loro gli studenti che
imparano concretamente la bellezza e la
complessità di dare forma alla materia
proprio attraverso il lavoro manuale
delle persone e questo vale ancora di
più quando a farlo è una persona in
condizione di fragilità
ci sono poi altri valori ci sono
i valori l'innovazione del lavoro perché
la connessione tra i nodi di rete la
collaborazione tra i nodi di rete
apporta novità significative al modo in
cui ognuno di noi persegue i propri
mandati professionali dentro il sistema
è fuori dal sistema
e poi siamo partiti dei materiali
torniamo ai materiali c'è il valore
ambientale perché all'interno di questo
sistema la materia circola non si ferma
e non produce più rifiuti tante cose
tanti i vantaggi e tutti nascono da un
cambio di punto di vista le opportunità
che trasformano le negatività i difetti
che diventano valori questo è il mio
modo di lavorare
questo è il mio modo anche personalmente
gratificante di lavorare di scrivere
storie di sviluppare progetti che forse
modelli più efficienti non guarderebbero
con interesse questo è il modo in cui
funziona un sacco di sport a questo
progetto sono molto grato per tante
ragioni ma due in particolari perché mi
ricorda ogni giorno che benessere
ambientale e legami sociali forti sono
inscindibili sono l'uno legato all'altro
e ancora ogni fallimento ogni progresso
ogni errore che affrontiamo in questo
progetto mi ricorda se non fosse
necessario quanto l'economia circolare è
tale solo se in grado di essere anche
sociale e civile
grazie
[Applauso]